[Music]
okay do I need to go check in on Baldi
hi my name is Markiplier and welcome to
bali's Basics and Nightmares I saw this
and I know I know what you're thinking I
know what you're thinking oh man Mark
don't you have a whole bunch of other
games that you have on your list that
you've been meaning to play and been
promising that you would play for a very
long time and yeah I do that's true very
much true but then I saw this
oh my god
um
I'm not gonna read that
[Music]
oh
my God
um
so I saw this and then I remembered that
oh yeah ball these Basics I haven't
heard about an update to that in a while
and this came out and I was like ah
those other things can wait survive 300
seconds and still unlock the secret
ending good luck make sure you have
visited the how to play tips for more
in-game tips okay welcomes to nightmares
nightmare Baldy's Dimension a look at
the left hole
what
[Music]
why is my power running out so fast okay
oh
my
oh God okay
all right I get it I get it okay
oh
okay
uh uh
oh
okay oh my God
oh my God
[Music]
I'm not doing this because I'm like oh
man it's so scary I'm doing this because
my brain is breaking as to how my life
decisions have led me to this point
right here right now
I can't fathom this game
I think they said the developer said
that this was made as like a joke right
and honestly you know I'm not trying to
like [__] on anything here I'm always
there down to encourage people to make
the things that they want to make and
I'm I'm here to give anything a try
because I remember baldi's Basics and I
feel like everyone seems to have
forgotten about baldi's Basics but I you
know I can't say that that game was made
well either but that was intentional and
I feel like this one's intentional so I
don't even know what okay Baldi will
appear either on the left right or
middle if he appears in the middle plays
sound okay if he appears on the right
press L if it appears on the left go
back L if 2D n principles meter to
police completely before send it
detention oh that's the thing on the top
okay appearing at random use of safety
scissors all right press E when he
appears
Q oh get rid of some characters here oh
God
[Music]
[Applause]
when I die to something I will go look
at how to beat it 300 seconds what have
I done what have I done
what have I done
I don't like that thing I don't like
that thing at all okay
[Music]
um
so
just any other Five Nights at Freddy's
fan game or you could probably say that
this is more of a baldi's fan game that
it is a Five Nights at Freddy's fan game
for sure for definitely sure
number one you can hear the sound every
time you change camera angles that
really makes it
and sweeping you know oh oh oh oh oh oh
almost
[Music]
oh
I'm having the best time that goes down
hi hello that could sound quick okay can
I just keep my mouse here is there any
other reason that I need to have it
anywhere else
sorry now that my FNAF instincts are
kicking in and my baldi's instincts oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait
oh my God this isn't actually supposed
to be stressful this isn't actually
supposed to be straining my my
magnificent abilities
why sorry I closed my eyes for a second
all right so there's no punishment for
hitting the sound when it's time to hit
it
oh oh my God
okay
so I know this is supposed to be
made uh as a joke but it's it's actually
not that bad except for the whole thing
where
the the machine kind of emerges from The
Ether that is a little weird
um but other than that it seems
manageable
hi
ah it's too oh my God oh my God
oh my God
what the hell
what the hell I think in the
instructions it said when it's on the
left you go quickly but I'm I'm kind of
moving quickly from it anyway so oh you
you yes so
um I guess just the moral of the story
is don't hang out in the left for any
reason
man that actually startled me I can't
believe I'm actually enjoying this
I mean I I never know if I'm actually
enjoying this whenever I play like a
FNAF fan game I don't know if it's just
because I'm being held hostage and it's
more Stockholm syndrome than anything
but it's weird right I I just I kind of
you know I have a giggle I'm having a
good time it's not bad I gotta make it
oh [__]
gonna make it to 300 seconds and that's
taken away by
the second now okay
uh you I'm gonna click outside of the
game and I'm gonna die because it's so
far away oh my no wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
a minute
you can't do that
you can't do that the only one that's
gonna throw me off is pressing L over on
the right there
I'm never gonna be able to get that
right
but I've almost got this
not today
thank you I don't know if that's it hi
God you always appear at the last frame
all right oh my God
why is that the most terrifying one
good
God okay uh at least I don't need to way
to duration to come back to it at least
it goes away immediately that's nice
oh
hi
yeah okay
what there's nothing there's nothing
happening there's nothing what do you
mean what
I can't move I'm winning what
all right
[Music]
what
what happened I don't understand
anything that happened
but I won I think I did
so
survive the real nice so was that
not
oh my God
why the items
foreign
[Music]
is that what this is so this wasn't even
the whole gate I thought this was all
part of the same game so all of this is
now useless to me oh my God Baldi will
appear in the room to the left he will
speak whenever he's about to attack make
sure to flash the light at him then make
sure you don't flash light when he isn't
there after he's disappeared what do you
mean
oh
man
click on him seven times right on the oh
man one B soda to let you pass into the
principles
oh man move right when at baldi's room
oh man
all right let me just go into it one
one instructions uh
uh cause hole
appropriate that this is cool because
that's a whole syllabus to be able to
learn anything about what's Happening
Here what do I do to you
you're looking for me what button do I
press I don't know so go to the right
for a for us something
what do I owe whoa
okay let me read this okay baldy will
appear in there on the left so we will
speak whenever he's about to attack make
sure to flash the light it and then you
can control to use your flashlight okay
oh e to shock first prize
space bar to jump flicker the flashlight
by controlling by pressing Ctrl if arts
and Crafters appears to get rid of it
super hard mode only nightmare
principally will require you to flicker
your light at him to make sure his meter
stays up if he's meter depletes to zero
you'll be teleported to his office for a
detention make sure to go to the room on
the right frequently for the principal
okay appearing right behind you make
sure to shock him with e okay got it
appearing only in the main area oh and
Left hallway Okay jump five times oh
actually she appears in left Hall too
spacebar when she's there also click on
him left seven okay and then soda oh
no okay I got the hiccups now I got the
fear hiccups
my computer is like burning alive trying
to render the sheer graphical Fidelity
of this beautiful School
Okay jump jump okay got it right
flashlight give give
okay I got two
okay right
normally when he's
up got it this shouldn't
be anything this shouldn't be anything
this should be nothing
oh oh okay
[Music]
look yeah
yep
yep wow you're awful oh man I I don't
even understand
okay
[Music]
I have no idea
horrible everything came about this
big nightmare
oh yeah there's my hall pass
don't know why you disappear unless you
go behind me
okay do I need to go check in on Baldi
check in on Baldi all right
oh man
is equipped to properly handle what is
happening it's not complicated
it's clearly not complicated I can do it
that's not a problem
the problem is will my sanity hold up
I don't hear anything
that is great
[Music]
I'm coming baldy hold on
oh oh oh right not again oh
oh
try it one more time that was I I don't
know why I pressed it twice in a row
that was
really my fault so it's that grumbling
you hear that grumbling that's him about
to
hack
and I'm good at that
okay
foreign
this is weirdly well polished compared
to the last one and I I'm like I'm
actually impressed because there's some
things going on here that are clearly
very well done
and that's cool
oh oh that's
well that that that is a problem but um
well uh what do I do the principle I'll
be putting detention if I
okay now don't look at him again oh God
principal please
I'll take that it's mine
perfect man I'm great
God damn I'm good at this game
but do I want to be do I wanna be
I don't hear any voice but then again
I've kind of Forgotten what the voice
even sounds like
principal oh that's yup okay it's pretty
clear
hurry up
oh please no right now I got a baldy
okay
oh okay so actually you know I'm doing
I can't really believe that I'm doing
okay but I am doing okay
oh seven times oh I did it
that's not the voice is it
is that the voice
I don't think that's the voice I don't
think that's the voice oh that's the
voice okay
all right I gotta go hurry up
[Music]
got him easy easy
I'll take that it's mine
oh what I was I was waiting oh you
that's cheap
I'm going back
oh
[Music]
easy easy
okay this stuff is easy
this is nothing I don't even need to go
nowhere okay
I'm gonna wait for one more here
easy
oh that's baldy all right
so thanks for making it obvious
nice easy
it's actually not too bad once you get
into flow it's it was daunting with the
sheer number of things to do
but yeah no this is not that bad
I got him
oh God oh God oh God wait wait wait wait
wait
oh
[Music]
man
oh God
[Music]
whoa Jesus what's happening
oh oh yeah that's that's okay baldi's on
the way okay
hold on baldy hold on there we go
patience Baldy
patience Baldwin
I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm going
I'm going almost there almost there I'll
take that it's mine now you can have it
more here
got it that'll probably carry me over to
the end of the night
wow you won the game
congratulations thanks
special all right good luck
but I don't want to do super hard mode
when I don't want any supermarket
wow
wow is that a [__] and balls
looks you can censor that that that you
can't show that on me
oh man
all right great stuff okay ah
good how do you do I'm not going to do
it I'm not going to do it I refuse to do
it but thank you everybody so much for
watching it was good to go back into the
Yonder years of baldi's Basics and also
Five Nights at Freddy's what a weird one
if you want to try super hard mode for
yourself Link in the description go
check it out right down there I won't
stop you and I don't think anybody
legally can thank you so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you